en france le premier ministre doit
détailler la face de lui des confinement
limitations de déplacements réouverture
des restaurants ou encore des lieux
culturels
les nouvelles mesures sont très attendus
réponse dans quelques instants
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur rt france à la
tente est grande et loire philippe doit
détailler la phase 2 du déconfinement
dans quelques minutes
on va partir tout de suite devant
l'hôtel matignon retrouver notre
reporter thomas bonnin thomas bonjour on
le disait un edouard philippe doit
s'exprimer dans très peu de temps
maintenant vous pouvez vous nous en dire
plus
oui la prise de parole du premier
ministre est imminente on a vu
d'ailleurs il a quelques instants le
ministre de l'éducation nationale jean
michel bancaire qui s'est rendu à pied
ici à l'hôtel matignon il participera à
cette conférence de presse l'idée pour
le premier ministre c'est de détailler
les modalités de cette deuxième phase de
déconfinement qui prendra effet à partir
du mardi 2 juin
les derniers arbitrages ont été pris
dans la journée aujourd'hui après la
tenue d'un conseil de défense et selon
les éléments qui circule depuis le début
de cet après-midi la règle des 100 km2
devraient être supprimés autres
modifications qui pourraient être
annoncées par le premier ministre celle
des départements en rouge il ne devrait
plus y avoir de départements rouge sur
l'ensemble du territoire en revanche il
pourrait y avoir maintenant des
départements en couleur orange notamment
ça pourrait être le cas de la région
d'île-de-france cet assouplissement
permettrait notamment la réouverture des
parcs et des jardins dans la ville de
paris d'ailleurs la mairie de paris
annonce sur son site internet
la réouverture prochaine des parcs et
des jardins dans la capitale autre effet
de cet assouplissement et bien les bars
et les restaurants pourraient être
amenés à accueillir à nouveau des
clients à partir de la semaine prochaine
en ce qui concerne la région ile de
france il ya encore certains doutent
peut-être qu'il ne pourrait s'agir là
que des terrasses des bars et des
restaurants
il reste encore toutefois quelques
inconnues notamment autour de la
situation dans les écoles dans les
collèges dans les lycées ou encore
autour de la situation de l'oral de
français pour l'épreuve du bac je
voulais dit jean michel blanquer
participent à cette conférence de presse
on devrait donc en savoir un peu plus
aux côtés du premier ministre
il y aura donc le ministre de
l'éducation nationale mais aussi le
ministre de la santé ils vont s'exprimer
dans les toutes prochaines minutes
merci beaucoup thomas pour ces
précisions on va vous retrouver 1 à
l'issue de la prise de parole du premier
ministre thomas abonnés en direct devant
l'hôtel matignon
et en attendant à cette prise de parole
du premier ministre nous accueillons
paul du verger il est président délégué
du syndicat des restaurateurs génie
faillite
philippe duverger merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france edouard fille va
donc s'exprimer dans quelques instants
est l'un des sujets les plus attendus
c'est bien la réouverture des
restaurants est ce que vous êtes
optimiste à quelques minutes de ces de
l'annoncé de ces nouvelles mesures
alors oui bien sûr qu'on est optimiste
c'est une date qu'on attend depuis
longtemps je vous rappelle qu'on était
les premiers est fermé et nous sommes
quasiment les derniers arrêts bon qu'il
est grand temps que cela se fasse ceci
posé nous attendons maintenant bien
évidemment les les conditions dans
lesquelles va se divertiront ce pertes
nous avons des idées à peu près précise
sur les sur le protocole sanitaire qui
quand même est assez important et nous y
veillerons à ce qu'ils soient appliqués
pour théoriser nos clients saas est
important maintenant ce que nous
attendons tout de suite après cette date
c'est des conditions économiques dans
lesquelles cette mère te va se faire
notamment en termes d'exonérations de
charges et de voir donc sur la durée
l'ensemble des mesures économiques qui
vont pouvoir être prises donc ça c'est
vraiment notre inquiétude
dernière chose bien évidemment on espère
que les réseaux d'orange ne resteront
pas orange très longtemps effectivement
ça nous inquiète un petit peu notamment
pour la région parisienne façon à ce
qu'on puisse ouvrir le plus rapidement
possible paul du verger on va y revenir
à la fois sur l'aspect économique et sur
l'aspect des zones orange
néanmoins à ce que vous avez été
consultée avant cet acte avant l'annoncé
de cette acné de déconfinement le génie
est en négociations avec le gouvernement
depuis depuis de longues de longues
semaines donc c'est vrai que nous avons
été consultés
on a demandé et le plus possible à être
prévenus en avance parce qu'il faut
préparer cette ouverture
alors on est tout à fait disposé à le
faire avec les autres coques de sécurité
le mieux nous avons participé activement
à l'élaboration de protocoles
donc on en est un petit peu responsables
même s'il ya des particularités et des
contraintes un peu importantes mais les
importantes ouvert parce que il faut
qu'on puisse ouvrir et faut surtout mais
je répète aussi baisser notre
rentabilité donc armand on n'entend pas
tout à l'heure alors l'état avait
annoncé une
you're dead pour aider votre secteur à
surmonter la crise sanitaire
malgré tout à ce que des restaurateurs
vont être obligés de fermer et dans
quelle proportion est ce que vous avez
une idée aujourd'hui on est jacques on
est inquiets les choses au clair on a
fait des tanks est au niveau national il
y à un mois
l'euro montait dans l'épreuve
aujourd'hui il y en a un petit peu plus
alors je pense qu'être l'inquiétude
maintenant très clairement on va voir ce
qui va se passer dans les deux prochains
mois et notamment avec les vacances pour
tout simplement savoir il joue comme je
le disais si le seuil de rentabilité va
être atteint en fonction de la baisse de
fréquentation puisque baisse de
fréquentation il y aura des bannières ou
d'une autre ne serait ce que par les
problèmes de distanciation ne serait ce
par les hôtesses qui ne seront pas là et
c'est donc de cesser tout simplement ça
de voir dans quelle mesure on va pouvoir
tenir
voilà et sur l'aide d'un qui avaient été
les mesures qui avaient été annoncés
pour aider les restaurateurs qu'en est
il aujourd'hui est-ce que ça a permis
effectivement de faire face à cette
crise alors pour l'instant en direct le
risque et le caractère d'urgence a été
sauvegardé prince dans les
établissements sont là maintenant dans
la durée c'est là où il faut qu'on
regarde il ne s'est pas en sorte de
baisser les charges avec un chiffre
d'affaires qui sera qu'on décide pour
l'instant à peu près de l'ordre de 50%
il va se passer il ya un moment où ça va
pas où ça va pas le faire donc c'est
bien là toute la difficulté donc alors
il ya eu des notamment les mesures de
chômage partiel qui ont été faits
ministre nous a garanti que ce serait
pour l'instant dans les mêmes conditions
jusqu'à fin septembre
mais pas aussi nous n'avons toujours pas
les décrets qui rompt qui sont partis a
été obtenu notamment l'exonération des
charges patronales jusqu'au mois de juin
mais quid jusqu'à la fin de l'année donc
voila un petit peu ce genre de ce genre
de questions il faut que l'on aborde
rapidement pour avoir une perspective de
rentabilité ce polar comment est ce que
les restaurateurs se prépare à la
réouverture de
de leur établissement quelles mesures
sanitaires vont être prises en d'autres
termes comment est-ce que cela va se
passer quand on voudra prendre un café
ou un jus d'orange sur une terrasse
alors très clairement
d'abord il ya un certain nombre de
mesures pour des postes de mesures
paritaires pour nos employés d'abord
déjà donc avec tout ça en termes de
contrôle en termes d'organisation à
l'intérieur de l'établissement en termes
de distanciation de travail en termes de
porcs du baht ont fait la rose et c'est
donc là c'est en train de se mettre en
place nous avons reçu trois balles de
d'avis sur les protocoles donc chacun
est en train de s'organiser en service
de ka jazz etcetera
maintenant qu'on de manière concrète ce
qui me paraît en plus c'est que le
masque sera donc demandée pour les
clients en dehors du là en dehors d'eux
lorsqu'il sera à table le masque sera
demandé également au personnel de salle
donc oui c'est déjà des contraintes
important il y aura bien sûr une mise à
disposition d'un gel à l'entrée
systématique du restaurant etc tedx
tentation de à mettre entre chaque table
ou si c'est pas le cas d'avoir une
protection en plexiglas
merci beaucoup paul du verger alors la
prise de parole d'edouard philippe a été
quelque peu retardé
néanmoins on vous retrouve à l'issue de
ces de l'annnonce de ces mesures merci à
vous peuple du verger je rappelle que
vous êtes président délégué du syndicat
des restaurateurs jeanny fagiht et les
mesures annoncées et qui vont être
annoncées par edouard philippe seront
appliquées dès le 2 juin réouverture des
bars hôtels restaurants on le disait
selon une source gouvernementale
l'exécutif envisage de les rouvrir
seulement en zone verte
en revanche en zone rouge et donc à
paris pourront accueillir le public à
partir du 1er juillet en tous les cas a
coulé à toulouse on s'impatiente
reportage hervé grand champ et lucas toi
à quelle sauce vont ils être mangé voilà
des semaines que les restaurateurs
attendent les annonces du gouvernement
pour savoir à quoi ressemblera leur été
dans ce quartier animé de toulouse
ceric julia espère pouvoir rouvrir son
établissement dès mardi prochain
nous nous attendions pas évidemment on
va fermer nous pensions que nous
pourrions effectivement avoir des
baisses liées au virus qui se développe
mais de la sq on ferme notre
établissement à aller au delà de tout ce
qu'on pouvait imaginer
nous n'avons absolument aucune idée de
la façon dont nous allons pouvoir ré
ouvrir et si on finissait l'exercice
2020 en atteignant 75 80 % du chiffre
d'affaires des années précédentes
je m'estime très satisfait donc nous
sommes 12 je pense qu'à la réouverture
seule une moitié de l'effectif redémarre
à compter du 2 à condition que nous
puissions redémarrer le deux une moitié
de l'effectif le bilan est parfois pire
dans les restaurants voisins c'est le
cas dans celui des rives
un restaurateur qui ne fait que de la
vente à emporter depuis un mois et demi
vraiment le 2 je continue ma formule 1
parce que j'ai peur je sais pas qu'est
ce qu'on va pouvoir faire mon restaurant
est trop petit
c'est un bistrot donc c'est l'étape les
unes sur les autres on peut pas de toute
manière
et les salariés malheureusement mais je
ne veux pas les reprendre j'en ai pas
avec moi est avec moi depuis le 15 15
avril
dans l'immédiat je vais continuer comme
ça j'ai pas le choix
mais je pense peut-être devoir
malheureusement de licencier du
personnel d
parce que je sais pas j'aimerais l'égard
des douches mais là
un flou qui devrait se dissiper dans
très peu de temps
le premier ministre doit s'exprimer cet
après midi et pour le ministre de
l'économie une chose est certaine
l'activité économique doit reprendre
bruno le maire s'est exprimé ce matin
sur france 2 écoutez le je souhaite oui
que nous puissions ouvrir le plus
largement possible et faire redémarrer
l'économie le plus rapidement possible
nous avons fait un choix qu'il a pondu
solitaire était le bon nous avons
confiné
nous avons des résultats sanitaires qui
du coup on s'améliore mais maintenant il
faut que l'économie redémarre parce que
les dégâts de cette crise sur le chômage
sur l'emploi sur les faillites
d'entreprises vont être considérables et
sont déjà considérables et je crois que
chaque français aujourd'hui le vit dans
son environnement immédiat les jeunes
qui veulent reprendre un travail les
salariés dont contrat n'a pas été
renouvelé
les dégâts économiques et sociaux sont
considérables et la seule réponse passe
par une reprise économique la plus
rapide possible économie toujours on
leur a appris en début d'après midi
l'entreprise goodyear en picardie a été
condamnée pour licenciement abusif 13
ans après le plan social et six ans
après la fermeture de l'usiné le
tribunal des prud'hommes d'amiens a
donné raison aux plus de 800 anciens
salariés injustement licenciés qui
devaient être indemnisés le jugement
s'applique dès à présent avec obligation
de payer aient la direction a pris acte
de son côté de ce jugement et indiqué se
réserver le droit de faire appel
le personnel soignant continue de se
faire entendre avec un rassemblement
devant l'hôpital robert debré à paris un
rassemblement organisé pour exprimer une
nouvelle fois les revendications des
blouses blanches
manifestations également à bordeaux une
centaine d'infirmières médecin un aide
soignant ou encore personnels
administratifs se sont donnés rendez
vous face ou chu cette manifestation
intervient alors que le ségur de la
santé entamer son 4e jour de
concertation le personnel soignant
espère que le gouvernement entendra à
leur demande écouter on a pris goût
beaucoup de manifestations avant deux
piliers le coc vide personne n'a voulu
rien entendre et heureusement sur le sud
ouest on a eu de la chance puisque on a
eu une grosse vague mais on était prêt
si on est à l'heure actuelle toujours
prêt mais si on avait pris en compte ce
que lors des manifestations selon
avaient tous dit on aurait pas eu tous
ces soucis tous ses problèmes internes à
ce que tous ces personnels
impacté par le club ce que j'attends de
la concertation de ségur
c'est que les jeunes aient suffisamment
envie de venir pour qu'on puisse avoir
suffisamment de bras pour travailler et
que ben en fait on est plein de gens qui
rêvent de faire notre travail et non
plus en tant des gens qui disent ah non
c'est dur à l'hôpital parce qu'à chaque
reportage vous nous dit à l'ats il ya
des conditions difficiles on a des
jeunes qui s'en vont on ne lâchera pas
parce que bon ben là il ya un gros
manque de personnel gros manque de
moyens de tous nos infirmières ben leçon
épuisé tout le monde est épuisé et je
pense que ben il faut qu'on se battre
pour tout ça on espère on espère que ça
changera quelque chose qu'on se mobilise
pour quelque chose n'est pas pour rien
qu'ils vont nous écouter
figure de la droite le député les
républicains claude goasguen est décédé
selon sa famille il est mort ce matin
l'âge de 75 ans il se remettait tout
juste du coronavirus l'ancien maire du
xvième arrondissement de paris avait
passé 22 jours en réanimation elle s'il
allait mieux il ensuite connu des
complications cardiaques et voit la
priorité au direct sur rt france le
premier ministre et loire philippe comme
on jouera des gosses
le 7 mai dernier
je vous ai présenté le plan que nous
avions préparé pour des confiner le pays
un plan qui suivait une ligne de crête
exigent beaucoup de prudence et de
méthode pour ne pas brûler les étapes et
risquer une seconde vague épidémique un
plan pour trois semaines du 11 mai au
1er juin
pour sortir du déconfinement le 7 mai
dernier je vous avais donné rendez-vous
pour vérifier précisément où nous en
serions pour savoir si oui ou non nous
serions en mesure de contenir l'épidémie
pour annoncer de nouvelles mesures à
nouveau pour les trois semaines
suivantes ce qu'on appelle la phase 2 du
déconfinement
et pour vous donner des perspectives
pour cet été pour partager aussi comme
nous le faisons régulièrement avec le
ministre des solidarités et de la santé
en toute transparence les chiffres qui
nous permettent de fonder nos décisions
et de construire notre stratégie eh bien
nous y sommes et si je devais résumer
l'ensemble des données qui vont vous
être présenté
je dirais que les résultats sont bons
sur le plan sanitaire
même si nous restons prudents même si
nous ne pouvons pas courir le risque de
la désinvolture
les nouvelles sont plutôt bonnes avec le
ministre des solidarités de la santé
nous allons d'abord partager avec vous
les données dont nous disposons nous
allons vous indiquez celle de nos
inquiétudes qui nous imposent de
demeurer vigilants puis je demanderai au
ministre de l'éducation nationale de
préciser les conditions dans lesquelles
nous allons pouvoir accélérer la reprise
de l'école c'est un sujet crucial
je présenterai enfin toutes les
décisions très concrètes que nous avons
prise ce matin en conseil de défense
sous l'autorité du président de la
république et la façon dont nous allons
organiser dont nous allons nous
organiser pour les trois semaines qui
viennent
mais avant tout cela un mot sur le bilan
pour suivre l'évolution du coc vite 19
dans le pays
nous vous avions présenté les
indicateurs qui permettait de distinguer
les zones dites rouges et les zones
dites vertes
la différence entre ces zones c'était la
circulation du virus
la disponibilité des lits de réanimation
et la capacité de tests pour déceler
d'éventuels gros démarrage de l'épidémie
avec ses indicateurs
quatre régions étaient en zone dite
rouge
aujourd'hui tous ces indicateurs sont au
vert à l'exception notable de deux
départements le val d'oise et mayotte
alors ça ne veut pas dire que le virus
ne circule plus ça ne veut pas dire que
le virus ne circulerait que dans ces
deux départements de mayotte et du val
d'oise pas du tout le virus est encore
présent à des degrés divers sur tout le
territoire
mais ça veut dire que sa vitesse de
circulation sa vitesse de propagation
est à ce stade sous contrôle ça veut
dire que nous en sommes là où nous
espérions nous trouver à la fin du mois
de mai est en réalité c'est même mieux
que cela
nous sommes un peu mieux que là où nous
espérions être
c'est donc une très bonne nouvelle et
cette bonne nouvelle n'est pas le fruit
d'un miracle c'est le résultat du bon
travail de tous ceux qui sont mobilisés
contre l'épidémie
les soignants bien sûr évidemment les
élus locaux aussi qu'ils ont su adapter
le plan de déconfinement à la réalité du
terrain en lien avec les préfets les
équipes des ars et de l'assurance
maladie qui ont pour mission de remonter
l'échelle de contiennent de
contamination c'est le fruit de leur
travail
c'est surtout le fruit de votre rigueur
et de votre civisme et je ne le dirai
jamais assez c'est le respect des
consignes la rigueur tranquille avec
laquelle nous mettons en oeuvre les
procédures de déconfinement qui
constituent nos meilleures protections
contre 1 re démarrage de l'épidémie
sur le plan sanitaire les nouvelles sont
donc bonnes bonnes mais pas suffisamment
bonnes pour dire que tout redeviendrait
normale
nous devons rester prudents et vigilants
pour trois raisons d'abord parce que le
virus continue à circuler je le disais
partout en france
de nombreux kloster surgissent
heureusement nous les détecte ont
rapidement mais ils sont toujours
porteurs de risques risques de
contamination important ensuite parce
que l'hôpital
même s'il a retrouvé une forme de
sérénité reste sous tension
il a subi vous le savez un effort
une pression absolument considérable
nous nous réjouissons tous évidemment
que le chiffre de personnes en
réanimation soit descendue de plus de
7000 au moment du pic à moins de 2000
aujourd'hui mais moins 2000 aujourd'hui
ça représente toujours 30% de notre
capacité de réanimation en temps normal
et c'est vraiment beaucoup
enfin nous connaissons de mieux en mieux
le virus et nous savons qu'il est
particulièrement virulent dans les
milieux fermés dans les grands
rassemblements et qu'il touche de façon
particulièrement sévère
les personnes précaires et vulnérables
tout ceci justifie donc que nous
restions très vigilants le ministre des
solidarités et de la santé va vous
présenter le dispositif de surveillance
qui est mis en place pour tous les
départements et qui permet partout sur
le territoire de prendre des mesures de
précaution si nécessaire tous les
départements vont bénéficier de
nouvelles mesures fortes de
déconfinement mais nous allons
surveiller avec une vigilance
particulière les départements
d'ile-de-france la guyane et mayotte
dans ces départements le site le virus
circule un peu plus qu'ailleurs et des
inquiétudes spécifiques demeure donc le
ministre de la santé y reviendra dans
ces départements
nous allons qualifié de départements
orange le déconfinement sera dans les
trois semaines qui viennent un peu plus
prudent que sur le reste du territoire
au cours de cette phase 2 je veux
insister sur cet élément qui est
important la liberté enfin va redevenir
la règle et l'interdiction constituera
l'exception
nous avons ainsi notamment décider
l'accélération de la réouverture des
écoles et collèges dans toutes les zones
et des lycées dans les départements vers
le ministre de l'éducation nationale il
reviendra dans un instant la réouverture
des cafés des restaurants des bars le
retour progressif de la vie culturelle
et sportive avec des contraintes
spécifiques dans les zones de vigilance
orange
la réouverture des parcs et jardins en
zone orange
mais cette liberté retrouvée implique
des contraintes qui sont en quelque
sorte des contreparties la limitation
des regroupements à 10 personnes dans
l'espace public est maintenu le principe
du recours au télétravail doit toujours
être privilégiés on le comprend bien le
respect des gestes barrières surtout
doit rester très rigoureux et le port du
masque est maintenant largement
recommandée par les autorités sanitaires
nous continuerons et j'en suis désolé
mais c'est mon devoir a limité les
formes de la vie sociale les plus
propices à la transmission du virus les
sports de contact les boîtes de nuit les
regroupements de très large public en
particulier le ministre le dira il faut
éviter les rassemblements de personnes
dans les lieux couverts et sans
organisation adaptée
enfin il faut continuer de veiller aux
personnes vulnérables et leur demander
de poursuivre leurs efforts pour se
protéger
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais avant de passer la parole au
ministre de la santé et des solidarités
également insisté sur l'urgence
économique et social qui vient ou en
vérité sur l'urgence économique et
social qui est déjà là le plan de
confinement nous a obligés à mettre à
l'arrêt une très grande partie de notre
économie nous avons su prendre les
mesures de chômage partiel pour limiter
l'impact de ce choc sur les entreprises
et sur leurs salariés nous avons mis en
place des dispositifs de solidarité
indispensable puissants qui sont venus
accompagnés qui accompagne eu du mieux
qu'il est possible
celles et ceux dont l'activité
économique se trouve interrompue mais
gardons en tête
gardons en tête que s'ouvre aujourd'hui
un nouveau front et que le pays va
devoir se battre contre l'impact d'une
récession historique
les chiffres présentés par pôle emploi
ce matin la teste essonne d'urgence
le nombre de personnes inscrites à pôle
emploi qui n'ont pas travaillé du tout
en avril a augmenté de plus de 800
milles par rapport à mars
c'est malheureusement historique le
déconfinement pas donc nous permettre de
reprendre une vie presque normale de
souffler après l'épreuve
mais il doit aussi sonner la
mobilisation de tous le moment d'une
reprise vigoureuse organisé déterminer
nous aurons l'occasion d'y revenir
je vais passer la parole au ministre des
solidarités de la santé olivier ferrand
pour qu'il nous fasse un point sur les
éléments et la situation sanitaire à ce
jour merci monsieur le premier ministre
je voudrais prendre un temps pour
détailler avec vous les quatre
indicateurs que nous avons mis en place
et que nous suivrons désormais le
premier indicateur
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'incidence la
pression épidémique est analysée grâce à
l'incidence c'est quoi une incidence
c'est le nombre de personnes infectées
sur une semaine sur cent mille habitants
cet indicateur nous lui avons mis de
seuil
d'abord entre 0 et 10 personnes
infectées sur 100000 au delà de 10
personnes nous atteignons un seuil qu'on
appelle le seuil de vigiles
et ensuite au dessus de 50 personnes
pour cent mille lorsqu'elles sont
infectés nous atteignons alors ce qu'on
appelle le seuil d'alert ces seuils
ils sont cohérents ils convergent
d'ailleurs avec les seuils retenus par
des pays voisins en particulier
l'allemagne
le taux d'incidence donc restent au
dessus du seuil de vigilance dans
plusieurs départements
cela veut dire que dans ces départements
le nombre de nouveaux cas de
contamination dans les sept derniers
jours reste encore suffisamment élevé
pour justifier une attention
particulière cette incidence est dans la
plupart des cas expliquée par la
présence de cas regroupés ce qu'on
appelle désormais les clusters vous les
connaissez et ses classes teurs sont
repérés analysé isolé dans certains
autres départements c'est le cas
notamment en ile de france qui est une
situation particulière c'est le niveau
de circulation du virus qui explique
cette incidence élevée sans que cela
s'explique principalement par des cas
groupés donc par des clusters avec des
chaînes de transmission le deuxième
indicateur
c'est le taux de positivité déteste les
fameux tests pcr
avec l'augmentation importante de nos
capacités de test avec l'augmentation
importante des indications de test
le taux moyen de positivité des tests
pcr réalisée chez des personnes qui sont
soupçonnées suspecte de souffrir du
cornât virus n'est plus que de 1,9 pour
cent et étaient bien supérieures pendant
la phase épidémique près de dix fois
supérieur à ce taux de 1,9 pour cent
c'est un paramètre qui est important à
surveiller parce qu'il nous permet de
détecter précocement des signes de
reprise de l'épidémie dans les
territoires et plus le taux est bas plus
nous testons des personnes qui ne sont
pas malades c'est à dire que plus nous
testons large plus les mailles du filet
sont étroites
le troisième indicateur c'est ce qu'on
appelle le fameux air effectif c'est le
facteur de reproduction du virus
vous le connaissez on vous l'a présenté
à plusieurs reprises c'est la
probabilité pour quelqu'un qui
contaminait de contaminer à son tour
d'autres personnes
si le r est supérieur à 1 ça veut dire
que chaque porteur du virus va
transmettre à son tour le virus à plus
d'une personne et donc l'épidémie
augmente
et lorsque le r est inférieur à 1 ça
veut dire ce qu'est le cas d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui sur la majeure partie du
territoire
on peut alors considérer que l'épidémie
régresse puisqu'une personne malade va
contaminer en moyenne moins d'une
personne autour d'elle ce qui fait
varier ce facteur air effectif
c'est vous c'est à dire c'est le
comportement que vous adoptez depuis
plusieurs semaines avec le respect des
gestes-barrières le respect de la
distanciation physique et c'est en
suivant rigoureusement ses mesures que
nous pourrons continuer de faire reculer
l'épidémie jusqu'à éradiquer la présence
du virus sur tout le territoire
enfin le quatrième indicateurs
c'est le taux d'occupation des
réanimations cet indicateur vous le
connaissez nous l'avions présenté lors
de la précédente conférence de presse
c'est un niveau qui reflète la
saturation des hôpitaux avec encore des
malades en grand nombre d'ailleurs dans
les réanimations de nos hôpitaux
nous avons modifié les seuils de cet
indicateur de manière à accompagner le
retour progressif à la normale ainsi
nous avons abaissé le seuil de vigilance
à 40 % alors qu'il était auparavant à
60% et le seuil d alerte à 60 % alors
qu'il était auparavant à 80 %
c'est-à-dire que lorsque il y à plus de
60% des patients qui sont en réanimation
à cause d'une infection à coronavirus on
considère que le seuil d'alerté est
dépassée
cet indicateur comme la fois précédente
nous l'appliquons à l'échelle régionale
car c'est à l'échelle des régions qu'on
doit penser le taux d'occupation des
hôpitaux et des réanimations vous voyez
sur la carte que les tensions sanitaire
reste importante dans la région ile de
france ainsi qu'à mayotte dans la région
grand est
nous avons passé depuis quelques jours à
peine sous le seuil nous sommes passés
sous le seuil de 40 % ce qui est une
bonne nouvelle et qui permet de classer
la région vente est désormais en verre
l'occupation des réanimations est un
point de vigilance important pour nous
d'autant plus que le nombre total de
patients en réanimation
les malades atteints du coronavirus
éléments
d'autres maladies reste à un niveau très
élevé ainsi vous avez la carte des
points de vigilance pour la phase 2 du
confinement que le premier ministre vous
a présenté et qui est ainsi basé sur ces
quatre différents indicateurs sur cette
carte est sauf pour l'île de france qui
est dans une situation particulière sur
laquelle je vais revenir les
départements en orange sont ceux pour
lesquels il ya au moins deux indicateurs
sur les quatre au dessus du seuil de
vigilance et pour lesquelles après une
analyse approfondie nous dit nous
considérons qu'il faut maintenir une
vigilance renforcée en ile de france
cette vigilance est justifiée en raison
de la persistance à la fois d'un taux
d'incidence encore élevé sur certains
départements de la région et d'un taux
de patients hospitalisés en réanimation
encore élevé pour l'île de france nous
avons considéré que les mesures doivent
être prises à l'échelle de la région et
non pas du département compte tenu d'une
part de la forte densité de la
population dans cette région mais
également des réseaux de transport et de
la grande mobilité des habitants à
travers les départements de la région
dans le département de mayotte la
vigilance renforcée est liée à
l'existence d'une épidémie toujours
active et à la persistance de tensions
sanitaires comme en attestent nos
indicateurs
enfin en guyane le classement en
vigilance renforcée et là aussi liée à
plusieurs indicateurs épidémique au
dessus des seuils de vigilance et
notamment un nombre est un effectif
supérieur à 1
démontrant la progression toujours
active de l'épidémie sur ce territoire
s'agissant des autres départements la
couleur verte ne veut pas dire que le
virus n'y circule plus et qu'il n'y ait
plus je le redis le comportement de
chacun est essentielle pour faire
progresser encore la situation
nous suivrons très attentivement avec
les indicateurs et avec les directeurs
généraux des ars et les préfets de
département la situation département par
département et notamment la surveillance
nous surveillerons l'émergence
d'éventuels cluster qui permettront à
chaque fois que ce sera nécessaire de
prendre des mesures territoriale adapté
parfois l'échelle d'un département
parfois d échelle plus petite ainsi que
nous l'avons d'ailleurs fait souvenez
vous au stade 1 mais également au stade
2 de l'épidémie parlons maintenant le
prix ministre des tests vous le savez la
france a déployé une stratégie offensive
qui tient en trois mots protégés restait
isolé afin de mieux contrôler la
diffusion du virus
grâce au déploiement massif des tests
pcr grâce à la mise en place d'un
système de centralisation numérique des
données
nous avons la capacité de tester chaque
personne symptomatique et tous les cas
contacts à risque et nous pouvons
également mené des programmes de
dépistage spécifiques à ce stade plus de
80% des résultats des tests pcr sont
rendus en moins de 36 heures notre
capacité de test nous met en possibilité
de faire hauteur de tests que nécessaire
nous notons toutefois qu'il y a moins de
malades en circulation et c'est une
bonne nouvelle sur le territoire
national et qu'il y a même moins de cas
contacts rapprochés que ce que nous
avions anticipé compte tenu du maintien
des mesures de distanciation physique
nous ne sommes donc pas du tout à
saturation nos capacités de test et je
les dis et 2% de positivité sont le
reflet des mailles assez serré nous
menons également des opérations en
population asymptomatiques dans les
toutes les régions du territoire
national y compris là où personne
n'appelle parce qu'il n'ya pas de
symptômes et ça nous permet de vérifier
que ce n'est pas parce qu'il n'y a pas
de symptôme qu'il n'y a pas une
circulation active du virus
nous avons une règle de conduite
garantir à tous ceux qui doivent faire
un test d'y avoir accès veiller à ce que
personne ne restait les caches et il me
revient à nouveau de vous inviter en cas
de symptômes fièvre douleurs
respiratoires toux la moindre hésitation
doit vous conduire à appeler votre
médecin pour qu'il puisse vous prescrire
un masque un test vous permettre de vous
protéger de vous isoler et de regarder
avec vous si vous avez pu éventuellement
contaminer des gens dans votre entourage
sans le savoir
je voudrais enfin ajouter un mot sur la
sérologie depuis quelques jours notre
capacité de tests c'est en effet enrichi
d'une nouvelle approche très importante
ce sont les tests sérologiques ces tests
ne permettent pas de détecter la
présence d'un virus mais la réaction
immunitaire est donc de savoir si une
personne a développé des anticorps
contre le virus et donc ça veut dire
qu'il a été exposé à la maladie avec ou
sans symptômes et qu'il en a gardé une
mémoire immunitaire dont on laisse dont
on estime qu'elle a vocation à protéger
vis-à-vis du risque de virus mais je
vais être très clair un test sérologique
positif ne doit absolument pas changer
votre comportement vous pouvez encore
contaminer d'autres personnes sans le
savoir parce que si vous serrer la main
de quelqu'un qui est malade même si vous
même ne tombez pas malade
vous pouvez ensuite serrés d'autres main
ou déposées du virus sur des surfaces et
ainsi contaminer d'autres personnes
les mesures de distanciation sociale
s'impose donc à tous avec une sérologie
positive ou négative
la haute autorité de santé a publié une
liste de tests
ces tests sont désormais prises en
charge à 100% par l'assurance maladie
lorsqu'ils sont prescrits évidemment par
un médecin et selon les indications de
la haute autorité de santé ainsi que
pour les personnels de santé et les
personnels des ehpad qui peuvent
désormais s'ils le souhaitent bénéficier
d'une sérologie en laboratoire j'insiste
la sérologie ne remplace pas le test pcr
la sérologie ne vous dira pas si vous
êtes malade un jour donné la sérologie
vous dira si vous avez été malade
par le passé il s'agit de tests qui sont
désormais fiable avec des critères
d'utilisation précis validé et l'accès à
ces tests rembourser ne se fera que sur
prescription évidemment merci monsieur
le ministre des solidarités de la santé
la deuxième phase de déconfinement dans
laquelle nous entrons va et c'est
heureux d'une certaine façon entraîné
nécessairement une multiplication des
interactions sociales et des contacts de
proximité notamment dans des lieux
publics
il peut arriver que lorsqu'on est dans
un lieu public avec d'autres personnes
on les connaît et que si l'on est malade
on soit en mesure de donner leurs noms
et éventuellement leur numéro de
téléphone à ceux qui doivent remonter
les chaînes de contamination et ça
permet de faire le travail efficacement
mais il peut également arriver chacun le
comprend bien que parce qu'on est dans
le métro dans le tramway on se trouve en
contact rapproché avec des gens qu'on ne
connaît pas qui ne nous connaissent pas
et dont par exemple l'exploitant de
transport en public ne peut dire ni à
l'un ni à l'autre
quels étaient les personnes autour de
lui
c'est la raison pour laquelle en plus
évidemment du respect systématique des
gestes barrières de la distanciation
physique
nous avons voulu sur proposition du
secrétaire d'état au numérique cedrico
que je veux remercier pour l'excellent
travail accompli en la matière nous
avons voulu mettre à la disposition des
français un outil complémentaire du
travail des enquêteurs sanitaires c'est
l'application mobile stop qu'ovide stop
qu'ovide n'est pas l'art magique contre
l'épidémie mais elle est un instrument
complémentaire d'autres instruments qui
nous permet de lutter contre elle et qui
va nous permettre de lutter demain
encore plus efficacement contre elle
c'est d'ailleurs parce qu'elle a été
conçue pour participer à l'effort de
lutte contre l'épidémie dans un certain
nombre de cas que le conseil
scientifique
l'académie de médecine l'ordre des
médecins
le comité pilote d' éthique du numérique
ont jugé utile
le recours à une telle application avec
les garanties qu'elle présente nous
avons comme je m'y étais engagé pris
toutes les garanties nécessaires sous le
contrôle du parlement dont les deux
chambres l'assemblée nationale et le
sénat ont donné hier leur feu vert
vigilants pour que stop qu'ovide
respecte les données personnelles et les
données de vie privée de tous ceux qui
l'utiliseront stop qu'ovide ne voulut
géolocalise ra jamais son utilisation
sera anonyme est temporaire
et l'état n'aura jamais accès aux
données permettant de vous identifier
pas plus qu'à vos contacts ce sont ces
garanties et ses garanties
scrupuleusement vérifiées qui ont
conduit la commission nationale
informatique et libertés la cnil a
validé à deux reprises le déploiement de
cette application pour cette échéance du
2 juin
d'entrée dans la seconde phase du
déconfinement il sera possible de
télécharger et d'installer cette
application c'est évidemment volontaire
c'est évidemment gratuit très simple
d'utilisation
elle permettra d'être alertés
immédiatement ci ayant été à proximité
de façon prolongée considère que c'est
moins d'un mètre pendant plus de 15
minutes dans les derniers jours avec une
personne qui vient d'être testée
positive
vous recevrez une alerte disant
attention vous êtes restés dans les
derniers jours
à moins d'un mètre et pendant plus de 15
minutes de quelqu'un qui a été testé
positif vous devriez donc immédiatement
restreindre vos déplacements vous isolez
consulter un médecin
allez vous faire tester et dans
l'intervalle de temps gagné grâce à
cette application on a un élément
extrêmement puissants de lutte contre la
propagation de l'épidémie pourquoi
j'invite tous ceux qui me regardent et
tous nos concitoyens à utiliser cet
outil complémentaire pour se protéger
mais aussi pour protéger leurs proches
et pour protéger les autres voilà ce que
je voulais dire s'agissant de cet outil
nouveau qui sera disponible à compter du
2 juin et je vais passer la parole sur
un sujet différent mais absolument
essentiel au ministre de l'éducation
nationale pour qu'il évoque avec nous
les conditions dans lesquelles nous
allons pouvoir accélérer la reprise de
l'école pour les enfants les collégiens
les lycéens de notre pays merci monsieur
le premier ministre
comme nous le disons depuis quelques
semaines la réouverture des écoles et
des établissements est une urgence
sociale c'est aussi un impératif
éducatif
faut-il râle le rappeler l'école est
bonne pour tous les enfants
et en période de crise peut-être encore
plus qu en période ordinaire
je voudrais d'abord remercier l'ensemble
des personnels de l'éducation nationale
ainsi que les élus qui ont
beaucoup travaillé depuis le 11 mai pour
arriver à ce début de réouverture qui a
eu lieu à partir de ce moment là et
notamment s'agissant des collèges aussi
pour les départements vert depuis le 11
mai la priorité est toujours la même
c'est garantir la sécurité des
personnels et des élèves
c'est pourquoi nous avons un protocole
sanitaire très rigoureux nous l'avons
mis en place pour donner les garanties
de santé à tous les élèves bien sûr mais
aussi les adultes et afin donc de
rassurer aussi l'ensemble du pays est de
permettre ce retour progressif souhaitée
par le président de la république et le
premier ministre
la méthode suivie est toujours la même
c'est celle du pragmatisme c'est aussi
celle de l'esprit collectif
nous avons donc travaillé avec les élus
qui ont été étroitement et ceux associés
à la réouverture des écoles
nous avons travaillé évidemment avec les
personnels et nous avons d'ailleurs
permis que les plus fragiles puissent
continuer à être au télétravail et puis
nous avons eu aussi un travail avec les
familles par l'information famille en
continuant à offrir un enseignement à
distance aussi et bien entendu en tenant
compte du fait que la situation au mois
de mai était une situation d' amorce une
situation nécessairement imparfaite mais
une situation qui permettait d
amélioration progressive
après cette amorce du mois de mai nous
devons arriver maintenant à une
amplification au mois de juin
et donc nous allons le faire dans le
respect du protocole sanitaire et en
ayant aussi à l'esprit ce que nous
préparons pour le mois de septembre
s'agissant des écoles je voudrais
commencer par faire un bilan de la
première phase que nous venons de
connaître depuis le 11 mai comme vous le
voyez sur la carte la plus de 80% des
écoles primaires ont été ouvertes et ce
chiffre progresse chaque jour c'est plus
de 90 % des communes qui ont décidé de
rouvrir leur école et nous travaillons
avec le 10 % des communes restantes pour
atteindre l'objectif de 100 % dès la
semaine prochaine
nous avons noté une légère différence
entre les départements qui se trouve en
zone rouge et les départements qui se
trouve en zone verte c'est d'ailleurs
normal si par exemple dans le
département du finistère 100 % des
écoles sont ouvertes dans l'oise qui est
un département qui a été
particulièrement touchés par l'épidémie
et bien 58 % des écoles sont ouvertes
et nous sommes en constante progression
on peut voir aussi la proportion des
élèves en école primaire
à ce jour on note encore une différence
sensible entre les départements verts et
les départements en zone rouge
certains départements ont accueilli peu
d'élèves
d'autres ont pu immédiatement en
accueillir plus de la moitié il est
évident que nous allons aller vers la
hausse dans l'ensemble des départements
le chiffre de 22 % d'élèves ne traduit
pas le fait qu' il y à plus d'élèves qui
ont retrouvé l'école puisque bien
entendu il ya des rotations par exemple
à bordeaux c'est près de 60% des enfants
qui sont retournés en classe depuis le
11 mai en réalité nous devons aussi
aller chercher les élèves qui en ont le
plus besoin c'est notre priorité c'est
une priorité sociale est une priorité
éducative
c'est notamment le travail des
enseignants mais aussi avec l'ensemble
des partenaires pour aller chercher ses
enfants ses élèves qui ont le plus
besoin de l'école mais qui parfois n'y
sont pas encore allés dans la phase 2
celle qui s'ouvre à partir du 2 juin
toutes les écoles seront ouvertes et
donc les dernières communes qui n'ont
pas encore ouvertes ouvriront toutes les
familles qui le souhaitent doivent
pouvoir scolariser leurs enfants au
moins sur une partie de la semaine comme
les règles sanitaires restent en vigueur
avec des contraintes qui nous le savons
tous sont fortes
il y aura toujours des groupes de 15
élèves maximum mais il est indispensable
de proposer un accueil complémentaire
aux familles c'est pourquoi nous
développons particulièrement au mois de
juin le programme sport santé et culture
civisme qui doit permettre d'avoir des
activités notamment sportives et
culturelles mais aussi d'éducation à la
santé et d'éducation civique
conçu avec les communes avec un
financement de l'état pour soutenir les
communes et nous signons de plus en plus
de convention pour cela de façon à ce
que cela se déploient pleinement au mois
de juin en d'autres termes les élèves
peuvent être soit en classe en petit
groupe soit dans ce type d'activité
notamment quand les parents doivent
travailler mais entendu c'est là aussi
un développement progressif tout ne sera
pas parfait du jour en lendemain ce qui
est important c'est de progresser
si je parle maintenant des collèges là
aussi on peut faire un premier bilan de
la phase 1 qui est très courte
s'agissant des collèges comme vous le
savez nous avons
ouvert depuis plus d'une semaine les
collèges zone verte
ils l'ont été à 95 5%
de nouveau je veux remercier à la fois
les professeurs les personnels et les
élus pour leur volontarisme qui a permis
ce succès nous avons aussi des données
sur les proportions d'élèves de collèges
seuls les élèves de 6e et de 5e et est
retourné dans les collèges de zones
vertes
cela représente 28 % des collégiens ce
chiffre là encore constituer un tremplin
pour une ouverture plus large que je
vais maintenant annoncée s'agissant donc
de la phase 2 ce qui va arriver au
collège à partir du 2 juin l'ensemble
des collèges vont désormais ouvrir que
ce soit en zone verte ou en zone orange
en zone verte cela signifie donc que
l'on n'ajoute la 4e et la troisième
après la 6e et la cinquième qui ont déjà
ouvert donc l'ensemble des classes sont
ouvertes en zone verte en temps en zone
orange
nous allons accueillir en priorité les
élèves de 6e et de 5e et si les
conditions matérielles sont réunies les
élèves des autres niveaux pourront
ensuite être accueilli nouveau
regarderont évidemment cela cas par cas
comme vous le savez aussi bien au mois
de juin qu'au mois de mai nous devons
avoir beaucoup de souplesse en regardant
ce qui se passe sur le terrain
protocole sanitaire est maintenu pour
les collèges aussi bien sur nos coûts
devront dès système d'alternance et là
aussi le système sport santé culture
civisme que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
peut s'appliquer pour les élèves des
collèges avant d'aborder la question des
lycées je voudrais faire un point rapide
sur la reprise de la scolarité des
enfants en situation de handicap
ils ont fait partie de nos premières
priorités nous y avons travaillé
beaucoup avec sophie cluzel en charge de
ce secteur et 80% des ulis donc les
unités spécialisées pour les élèves en
situation de handicap ont pu rouvrir
dans les écoles et dans les collèges
cela signifie que entre 20 % et 50 % des
élèves ont pu y être accueilli en
présence
c'est évidemment un progrès important ça
n'est pas suffisant et nous voulons
aller plus loin et nous avons ce sujet
au coeur de nos priorités
comme partout notre objectif est donc
d'arriver à ce que dès la semaine
prochaine
100% des ulis soit ouverte enfin je
voudrais parler des lycées
en commençant par dire que notre
première priorité c'est les lycées
professionnels sont au coeur de notre
attention d'abord parce qu'il ya plus de
décrochage en lycée professionnel et
ensuite parce qu'il ya des besoins
particuliers en ce mois de juin si je
fais un point sur la situation donc à
partir du 2 juin l'ensemble des lycées
vont ouvrir avec un protocole sanitaire
qui est le même que pour celui des
collèges en zone verte
cela signifie que les lycées généraux
technologiques et professionnels vont
rouvrir et accueillir progressivement
les élèves au moins sur l'un des trois
niveaux pour commencer ensuite ils
pourront évidemment ouvrir d'autres
niveaux en fonction des situations
locales
là aussi nous laissons beaucoup de
souplesse faisant confiance aux
proviseurs et aux équipes localement
avec un travail qui je tiens à le
souligner comme pour les départements a
bien commencé avec les régions en zone
orange
nous sommes évidemment plus prudents les
lycées professionnels ouvrent aussi mais
il accueille en priorité les élèves qui
ont besoin de certification
professionnelle c'est-à-dire les élèves
de terminale et les élèves de ce et ap
pour les lycées généraux et
technologiques
les élèves sont accueillis sur
convocation de l'équipe éducative pour
des entretiens individuels du travail en
tout petit groupe d'ici à la fin de
l'année l'objectif que nous nous fixions
pour les élèves donc des lycées généraux
et technologiques de la zone orange
c'est qu'ils puissent avoir bénéficié d'
entretien pour faire le point sur leur
projet d'orientation et éventuellement
s'agissant des élèves de terminale sur
le suivi de parcours sup enfin et pour
terminer je voudrais parler de l'épreuve
anticipée de français depuis le début de
cette crise sanitaire
nous avons eu toujours trois facteurs
pour raisonner sur cette question la
sécurité sanitaire des personnels et des
élèves
le la bienveillance vis-à-vis de chaque
élève nous voulons les et personnes et
maintenir l'exigence de nos
enseignements et de nos examens
ce sont ces critères qui m'ont déjà
conduit à aménager les épreuves du
baccalauréat et ce sont les mêmes
critères qui nous conduisent aujourd'hui
à prendre une décision sur l'épreuve
orale de français j'avais indiqué que
c'était en cette fin de semaine que nous
pourrions prendre cette décision nous
sommes donné le temps qui étaient
nécessaires en étant attaché au fait que
les élèves travaillent le plus longtemps
possible ses textes qui sont importants
je rappelle que l'oral est une
compétence indispensable à la réussite
personnelle et professionnelle
elle est au coeur de la réforme du
baccalauréat et que la littérature est
une discipline majeure pour la formation
de l'esprit humain
nous devons veiller à ce que donc en
toute circonstance la continuité des
apprentissages et des examens soient
garantis j'ai consulté une nouvelle fois
les fédérations de parents les
organisations syndicales
j'ai présidé hier le conseil national de
la vie lycéenne je veux remercier tout
particulièrement les lycéens et leurs
représentants ont été très nombreux à
participer
j'ai entendu leur inquiétude face à une
situation exceptionnelle qui a entraîné
une inégale préparation nous entendons
donc l'argument qui considère que
l'évaluation la plus juste des
connaissances des élèves en français et
de prendre en compte les notes des deux
premiers trimestres de l'année et donc
par conséquent l'épreuve orale de
français sera validée par le contrôle
continu
c'est un acte de profonde confiance dans
le travail réalisé par les professeurs
et aussi dans le travail réalisé par les
élèves je serai très attentif à la suite
du parcours des élèves de première de
cette année notamment pour ce que pour
que leur apprentissage leur permettre de
préparer au mieux leur baccalauréat
je serai donc très attentifs à cela et
je vous remercie
merci dossier le ministre de l'éducation
nationale sans transition vraiment sans
transition je voudrais évoquer ici
l'ensemble des décisions qui ont été
prises ce matin à l'issue du conseil de
défense présidée par le président de la
république et notamment je ne la
question attendue espérée par beaucoup
celle des cafés et des bars et des
restaurants
le redémarrage de ce secteur des débits
de boissons en général fait et c'est
bien légitime l'objet d'une très forte
attente des français
c'est un secteur qui est capital pour
notre économie c'est un secteur qui est
capital pour l'emploi et c'est aussi il
faut bien le reconnaître il faut s'en
réjouir une partie de notre art de vivre
et de notre façon de vivre
collectivement et de vivre ensemble
compte tenu de l'évolution de la crise
sanitaire les restaurants bars et cafés
pourront ouvrir dans tous les
départements à partir du 2 juin mais ils
ouvriront avec des restrictions
temporaires dans ceux qui se trouvent
dans les zones oranges
là où une vigilance particulière est
nécessaire partout cette ouverture sera
conditionné au respect des règles
sanitaires qui ont été validés avec la
profession d'ailleurs les personnes qui
ont choisi de dîner ou de déjeuner
ensemble pourront s'asseoir à la même
table dans la limite d'une capacité
maximale de 10 par table mais il devrait
y avoir une distance minimale d'un mètre
entre les tables de chaque groupe les
circulations à la terre des
établissements devront être organisées
et le port du masque sera rendue
obligatoire pour l'ensemble du personnel
en salle et en cuisine ainsi que pour
les clients lorsqu'ils se déplacent bien
entendu s'agissant des bars toujours
dans les zones vertes je vous rappelle
la règle il faut te éviter les risques à
l'intérieur des espaces dans les
endroits où on est rassemblée
potentiellement plus serré et où la
circulation de l'air le renouvellement
de l'air est moins bien garantie c'est
pour ça que nous demanderons aux
exploitants de ne pas autoriser la
consommation debout à l'intérieur dans
beaucoup de cas ces deux barrières des
tables où on peut boire un verre ou
manger ça ne posera pas de problème mais
serra on demandera de ne pas autoriser
la consommation debout à l'intérieur
dans les départements qui font l'objet
d'une vigilance particulière les
départements de l'île de france
mayotte et la guyane
seuls les terrasses des cafés et des
bars et des restaurants pourront ouvrir
au 2 juin
j'ai parfaitement conscience que c'est
une restriction et que c'est une
restriction qui est lourde de
conséquences s'agissant de ces
établissements dans les zones oranges
mais il nous a semblé à la lumière de ce
qui se pratique dans les autres pays à
la lumière des risques que nous avons
identifié que c'était la bonne mesure à
prendre au moins pour les trois semaines
qui viennent
évidemment comme pour toutes les mesures
que je viens d'évoquer elles seront
réévalués
à la fin du mois de juin ou plus
exactement avant le 22 juin qui est la
date de notre prochain rendez vous un
mot sur les hébergements touristiques
les hébergements touristiques les
villages vacances les campings pourront
ouvrir à partir du 2 juin dans tous les
départements à l'exception de ceux qui
font l'objet d'une vigilance
particulière dans ces départements la
les hébergements question des campings
les auberges collectif ne pourrons
rouvrir que dans la troisième phase de
déconfinement c'est à dire après le 22
juin dans tous les départements les
colonies de vacances pourront re ouvrir
à compter du 22 juin
et c'est évidemment une bonne nouvelle
s'agissant des déplacements
depuis plusieurs mois nous avons voulu
éviter à tout prix que des personnes en
provenance de zones dans lesquelles le
virus circule puis se déplacer dans des
zones dans lesquelles le virus circule
ré - est-ce que l'idée c'était
évidemment d'éviter la dissémination du
virus
c'est pour cette raison que nous avons
fermé nos frontières les frontières
extérieures à l'europe et les frontières
intérieures à l'europe c'est aussi pour
ces raisons que lors de la première
phase du déconfinement nous avons décidé
d'interdire les déplacements de plus de
cent kilomètres à l'intérieur du
territoire national
sauf motif impérieux aujourd'hui le
virus circule encore très activement
dans certaines parties du monde
c'est pourquoi nous avons décidé
d'évaluer à la région du 15 juin avec
l'ensemble des pays européens
si nos frontières extérieures à l'europe
devait ou non réouvrir pour quel
ressortissant de quel pays
et avec quelles modalités de 14 n le cas
échéant donc pour tout ce qui est à
l'extérieur de l'espace européen
la décision sera prise collectivement
avec l'ensemble des pays européens à
l'horizon du 15 juin à l'intérieur de
l'europe
l'épidémie est en train de ralentir
c'est vrai en france mais c'est vrai
partout en europe
c'est pourquoi la france sera favorable
à une réouverture des frontières
intérieures de l'europe à compter du 15
juin si la situation sanitaire le permet
bien entendu 114 haine pour les
voyageurs en provenance de pays
européens
mais comme nous le faisons depuis le
début de la crise nous appliquerons des
mesures de réciprocité vis-à-vis des
états européens qui déciderait de fermer
leurs frontières ou d'imposer des 14 n
aux français à l'intérieur du pays
en france comme je l'expliquais même si
certains déplacement nécessite encore
une vigilance importante
la tension est globalement moindre qu'au
début du déconfinement la mesure
d'interdiction de déplacement de plus de
100 km a été très utile durant ces trois
dernières semaines pour limiter la
propagation du virus
elle a été bien respecté par les
français je les en remercie mais
aujourd'hui avec la pression qui a
baissé
cette mesure n'a plus de justification à
compter du 2 juin
il est donc mis fin à l'interdiction de
déplacement de plus de 100 kilomètres de
chez soi
je voudrais dire que la fin de cette
interdiction ne doit pas signifier un
relâchement dans la tension
il est bien vrai que - on circule moins
le virus se propage aussi j'en appelle à
la responsabilité de chacun vous pouvez
vous déplacer vous pouvez aller en
congés annuels
mais dans toute la mesure du possible si
vous pouvez différer un déplacement
lointain
c'est probablement plus raisonnable et
j'appelle chaque français dans le cadre
de ces nouvelles règles au même esprit
de responsabilité dont ils ont fait
preuve depuis le début de cette crise un
point sur un point important pour tous
nos concitoyens sur la culture les
loisirs et les vacances grâce aux
efforts faits par chacun pour respecter
les gestes barrière la distanciation
physique notre vie sociale notre vie
culturelle notre vie sportive va pouvoir
reprendre
plus largement je les dis dès ce
week-end les parcs et jardins seront
ouverts sur tout le territoire en zone
dite orange comme partout en france le
port du masque pourra être imposé dans
de nombreux espaces à la demande des
maires à la demande des maires les
préfets pourront par mesure de
précaution supplémentaire imposé le port
du masque dans les espaces publics
ce sera aux acteurs locaux d'en décider
à compter du 2 juin
seront aussi est également ré ouvert sur
tout le territoire les plages les lacs
les plans d'eau les musées les monuments
sont également ouverts sur l'ensemble du
territoire le port du masque
il sera lui aussi obligatoire pour un
certain nombre d'activités
une distinction va cependant devoir
encore être réalisées dans les trois
prochaines semaines entre les zones
vertes et les zones oranges dans les
zones vertes et salles de spectacles et
les théâtres pourront ouvrir à compter
du 2 juin
je ne méconnais absolument pas la
difficulté pratique de réouvrir ses
équipements dès lors que la
programmation s'est trouvée perturbée
que les répétitions n'ont pas pu
intervenir mais il nous semble que si
certains peuvent le faire alors qu'il le
fasse les règles de distanciation
physique devront y être respecté par une
organisation spécifique des places
assises une gestion des flux conformes
au protocole sanitaire de ces espaces et
le port du masque
il sera obligatoire dans les mêmes zones
vertes les activités sportives pourront
aussi ouvrir plus largement avec
l'ouverture des gymnases et des salles
de sport je sais que c'était une
décision attendue par beaucoup à l
approche de l'été les piscines
ils feront également ouvertes dès le 2
juin toujours dans les zones vertes les
parcs de loisirs seront ouverts pour les
activités permettant la distanciation
physique avec le respect de règles
strictes et notamment une jauge maximale
de 5000 personnes permettant là encore
d'éviter les trop grands brassages de
population pour les installations que je
viens de citer les salles de spectacles
des théâtres gymnases et salles de sport
les piscines les parcs de plein air
elles ne seront ouvertes dans les zones
orange qu'à compter du 22 juin
enfin partout sur le territoire les
cinémas rouvriront à compter du 22 juin
c'est une demande qui nous a été fait
par les exploitants de cinéma eux-mêmes
qui voulait que la réouverture soit
nationale de façon à pouvoir organiser
la programmation des salles et nous
faisons droit à cette demande
elle interviendra à compter du 22 juin
prochain
je voudrais insister sur le fait que
notre notre plus grand de notre plus
grand adversaire
ce sont les très grands rassemblements
il le risque est d'autant plus fort
qu'il aurait lieu dans un espace confiné
couvert et sans organisation spécifique
dans les espaces de plein air une jauge
maximale de 5000 personnes qui pourra le
cas échéant être revue à la baisse par
les préfets sera fixé dans les espaces
couverts est confiné par exemple les
salles de concert et en fonction de
l'activité les exploitants devront
proposer et garantir des règles d'usagé
adaptés notamment sur la capacité
d'accueil et la distanciation physique
nous partons là encore sur une logique
qui est logique de prudence mais qui est
aussi logique de confiance et nous
considérons que au stade où nous nous
trouvons de l'épidémie les exploitants
de lieux ouverts ou fermés et plus
exactement au couvert ou de plein air
sont capables de déterminer les
conditions d'organisation de leur salle
les conditions de déambulation les
conditions de croisement de
distanciation physique et que s'ils sont
capables de les organiser alors ils
doivent le mettre en oeuvre de façon
très stricte et que s'ils ne sont pas
capables de l'organiser et de le
garantir
alors il est préférable qu'il n'ouvre
pas cette à eux que revient cette
responsabilité est bien entendu les
services de l'état et je le crois
volontiers l'ensemble des collectivités
territoriales les assisteront pour faire
en sorte que cette réouverture puisse se
passer dans les meilleures conditions
jusqu'au 21 juin au 22 juin en vérité un
certain nombre d'interdictions vont
demeurer dans les lieux qui ne sont pas
organisés ou plus exactement qui nous
qui peuvent pas l'être qui ne doivent
pas l'être d'ailleurs les dieux qui ne
sont pas sous la responsabilité d'un
gestionnaire d'équipement dans l'espace
public par exemple les rassemblements
resteront limitées à 10 personnes
les événements culturels et sportifs
organisés dans l'espace public resteront
donc suspendu jusqu'au 21 juin au moins
et dans toute la france les discothèques
les salles de jeu les stades les
hippodromes
dont l'essence même est de rassembler
les gens dans un esprit festif resteront
fermés au public jusqu'au 21 juin - je
les dis dans le même esprit les sports
collectifs notamment les sports de
contact resteront également interdit
parce que ils ne permettent pas par
nature de respecter la distanciation
physique
les sportifs de haut niveau et
professionnels pourront néanmoins
reprendre les entraînements le 2 juin
dans le cadre d'un protocole médical
strict un mot sur la situation de nos
concitoyens les plus vulnérables
c'est-à-dire ceux exposés avec le plus
de risques au virus et à la maladie qui
en découlent il est vrai que nous
déconfit non le pays parce que le virus
circule moins mais nous devons conserver
une vigilance maximale pour protéger les
personnes à risque les personnes les
plus susceptibles d'être frappés par les
cas graves de la maladie
ce sont nous le savons les personnes qui
ont des maladies préexistantes qui
souffrent de surpoids de diabète
d'affections pulmonaires
bref qui ont des facteurs fragilisent
ans est particulièrement fragilisant
s'il devait être un malade et puis aussi
les personnes âgées de plus de 65 ans
dont nous savons qu'elles sont plus
exposés que statistiquement elles sont
beaucoup plus victimes de la maladie que
les autres pour cela il faut appliquer
rigoureusement les gestes barrière
pratiquer la distanciation physique on
ne le dira jamais assez limité les
contacts quand on est une personne
vulnérable à limiter les contacts ça ne
veut pas dire les interdire ça ne veut
pas dire les proscrire ça veut dire
faire en sorte de là encore faire
confiance à l'intelligence de ceux qui
se savent fragile et à la vigilance de
ceux qui les entourent
pour limiter ses contacts
les personnes vulnérables qui
travaillent doivent à chaque fois que
c'est possible
continuez à télétravailler quand ça
n'est pas possible
elles continueront à être indemnisés au
titre de l'activité partielle nous avons
également mis en place une consultation
qu'on appelle bilan et vigilance qui est
prise en charge à 100% par l'assurance
maladie
pour ceux qui n'ont pas consulté leur
médecin pendant la période de
confinement et qui doivent
impérativement le faire de façon à
vérifier que le ray
la santé et ne doit pas faire l'objet
d'une surveillance particulière ou de
mesures ou de traitement particulier
enfin pour ceux qui se posent des
questions sur le virus et sur les moyens
de protection en particulier pour les
personnes isolées
nous avons mis en place le numéro vert
que vous connaissez le 0 800 130 000 qui
demeurera actif j'ai eu plusieurs fois
l'occasion d'évoquer de façon spécifique
la situation des outre mer français
vous le savez parce que ce sont souvent
des territoires insulaires à l'exception
de la guyane ils sont souvent des
territoires plus fragile par leurs
équipements sanitaires et parfois par
des fragilités d'un certain nombre des
populations qui y vivent
la nouvelle phase de déconfinement va
être engagée évidemment dans les
outre-mers aussi en conservant cependant
des mesures de contrôle très strict des
déplacements vers ces territoires et des
mesures strictes de 14 n
lorsque on y arrive nous visons toujours
si les conditions sanitaires nous
permettent une ouverture plus large des
vols pour les vacances c'est essentiel
pour ces territoires d'ici larmes
nous allons expérimenter et je parle
bien d'une expérimentation une nouvelle
forme de 14 n dans certains territoires
avec un test qui sera réalisé au bout de
sept jours et pourra conduire s'il est
négatif à adapter les contraintes
imposées aux personnes
il faut que nous soyons en mesure
d'imaginer les bons distincts les bons
dispositif pour les territoires
insulaires c'est une c'est un impératif
qu'ils nous demandent
et c'est sur quoi nous nous sommes en
train de travailler à mayotte
l'épidémie reste active une première
évolution du déconfinement a été décidé
lundi dernier avec la réouverture de
certaines écoles mais nous allons rester
extrêmement vigilant nous allons
d'ailleurs resté également vigilant sur
la situation en guyane compte tenu de la
taille de certains cluster compte tenu
aussi de la situation dans le pays
frontaliers de la guyane et le brésil
des renforts de personnel pour les
équipes mobiles sont prévues et le
préfet de guyane pourra continuer à
limiter les déplacements de population à
l'intérieur du département c est
évidemment essentiel quelques mots sur
les perspectives pour l'été
chacun dispose je crois d'un peu plus
d'éléments pour organiser la période
estivale les déplacements y compris en
europe seront je l'espère autorisée
concernant les relations hors europe
il nous faudra nous harmonisé avec nos
pays voisins et prendre des décisions en
fonction de l'état et de l'évolution des
risques je les dis les enfants pourront
être inscrits en colonie de vacances ou
encore de plein air et nous avons laissé
des points d'interrogation que nous
devront lever dans les trois semaines
sur les rassemblements de plus de 10
personnes dans les espaces publics qui
vous permettrait la réouverture des
événements culturels et sportifs sur
l'ouverture des stades au public sur la
pratique des sports collectifs et de
contacts
cette réouverture sera examinée en
fonction de la situation sanitaire d'ici
le 22 juin
tous les ministres seront conduits à
préciser rapidement le détail des
mesures que nous vous avons présenté le
décret qui les organisent qui les fixe
qu'il est précise sera pris ce week-end
pour traduire en droit ces mesures je
voudrais je voudrais en appeler à chacun
de nos concitoyens à l'esprit de
responsabilité que j'ai souvent invoquée
à ce pupitre
les règles sont une chose il faut le
préciser de la manière la plus détaillée
possible il faut les pensées de la façon
la plus adaptée possible mais l'esprit
de ces règles est à l'évidence encore
plus important que la lettre de ces
règles et l'esprit de ces règles c'est
la race pense c'est la responsabilité de
nos concitoyens c'est le fait de
comprendre que nous sommes tous
collectivement quel que soit notre âge
quel que soit notre statut nos activités
notre situation un des acteurs de la
lutte contre l'épidémie s'agit pas
d'avoir peur
il s'agit pas d'avoir peur des autres
certainement pas il s'agit d'être soi
même suffisamment méticuleux et
organisés pour être certain de se
protéger soi-même et de protéger les
autres
dans l'ensemble vous avez parfaitement
compris ses règles elles sont bien
observer et c'est d'ailleurs la raison
pour laquelle l'épidémie recule mais
nous savons tous que le début d'un
relâchement une forme de désinvolture la
facilité du printemps et peut-être même
encore plus de l'été pourrait faire
repartir dans certains territoires
l'épidémie c'est la raison pour laquelle
je demande à chacun d'avoir le bon sens
qui est heureusement très développé dans
notre pays
le bon sens de comprendre ces règles et
dans toute la mesure du possible à
chaque instant de les respecter et de
les appliquer et je dis aussi que cette
bataille
cet effort contre l'épidémie si elle
progresse dans une bonne direction doit
se doubler dans les jours dans les
semaines dans les mois qui viennent
d'une mobilisation pour permettre à
notre pays de faire face à une deuxième
crise après la crise sanitaire qu'est la
crise économique et sociale que
j'évoquais au début de notre
intervention
je vous remercie beaucoup et je vais
évidemment enfin nous allons d'ailleurs
évidemment répondre à vos questions qui
nous seront désormais posée bonjour
monsieur le premier ministre
bastien auger tf1 lci nous allons vous
relayer les les questions voilà les
mesures concernant la deuxième étape du
déconfinement viennent donc d'être
annoncée par le premier ministre il
était accompagné des ministres de la
santé et de l'éducation nationale alors
avec les départements d'île de france
guyane et mayotte qui passent à l'orangé
tous les départements hauts vers un
retour à une vie un peu plus normale et
est donc possible
parmi les me
or qui entreront en vigueur le 2 juin
entre autres la fin de l'interdiction
des déplacements de plus de 100 km la
réouverture des parcs jardins des plages
la réouverture des écoles également des
commerces des lieux culturels ou encore
à la possibilité d'utiliser
l'application stop qu'ovide mais aussi
la très attendue réouverture elle des
bars et des restaurants et justement
pour en parler
paul du verger président délégué du
syndicat des restaurateurs génie s'agite
est avec nous peuple du verger
merci de répondre à nos questions alors
peut-être votre première réaction à les
restaurants situés en zone verte
pourront donc ouvrir le 2 juin vient de
l'apprendre seulement en terrasse un en
zone orange quelle est votre première
réaction après ces mesures annoncées par
le premier ministre alors je crois qu'il
y ait déjà un soulagement ou la quasi
totalité des départements dont passait
vraiment plus important maintenant on
espère très rapidement nos rôles
deviennent vite vers parce que là aussi
notamment paris qui a déjà que je perds
beaucoup je rappelle également la piste
et gilet jaune dont ils ont ils sont à
double peine pour eux donc il est
vraiment grand temps au pari qu'ils
restaurent puisse ouvrir parce que là
bien sûr il ya tout à la table de
restaurant qui vaut ne pas voir où et
qui vont nous attendre par semaine de
plus sachant effectivement que tous les
restaurants à paris n'ont pas de
terrasse alors concernant les mesures à
ces 10 personnes maximum par table
distance d'un mètre entre chaque table
port du masque obligatoire pour les
personnels et les clients lors des
déplacements dans les bars pas de
consommation debout bref toutes ces
mesures finalement et vous semble
facilement applicable alors facilement
en tout cas la somme nécessaire à
l'élaboration du protocole
on a fait 1 on a eu un sens de la
responsabilité mais également un petit
peu de l'accueil parce qu'on est dans ce
tome était là on espère que ça va
pouvoir être à court terme rapidement on
est comment dire que toutes ces mesures
vont pouvoir s'installer notamment le
port du pasteur en salle il n'est pas
très conviviale mais tant qu'il faut le
faire et qu'on ne peut faire comme ça
que rien faire du tout de toute façon
alors en tout cas maintenant les
restaurateurs ont jusqu'au 2 juin pour
se préparer
quels moyens ont-ils besoin pour
réamorcer leurs ouvertures
d'établissements voilà chacun cela
chacun va se mettre au travail
nous avons quelques soucis notamment
pour orienter les approvisionnements
puisque fournisseurs attendait les dates
les abattoirs ont été fermées etc
donc je pense que tout ça va se mettre
dans 15 à certains qui n'ont pas
réellement de loin ça va se mettre en
place progressivement dans le courant de
la semaine prochaine
donc ça c'est important après deux bons
tickets le restaurateur qui en fonction
de leurs bas vont peut-être choisir de
ne pas ouvrir notre banc est ce que les
consommateurs pourraient voir les
prestations offertes augmenté avec un
prix augmenter à cause de la crise
sanitaire
d'une part on a constaté quand même une
cherté des prix alimentaires doit avoir
des fruits des légumes de la viande donc
là on n'en pas de regarder un peu ça
d'un peu plus près c'est très clairement
les prix sont plutôt à la hausse
très clairement également mesures
sanitaires ont des ondées coupe en
termes d'organisation en termes
d'investissements donc là on va faire en
sorte de minimiser cet impact
mais ce n'est pas impossible qu'il y ait
un impact est ce que vous demandez des
mesures très concrètes
aujourd'hui au gouvernement des aides
pardon très concrète aujourd'hui au
gouvernement pour vous aider finalement
à
ouvrir les établissements en france
alors au reer en valeur il faut c'est ne
pas les refermer et à partir à fond pas
les refermer ayons des perspectives en
termes économiques et de savoir qu'on
puisse laisser notre rentabilité
comme je vous l'avais dit précédemment
obtenu l'abrogation des charges
patronales pour le mode loin mais quid
du mois de jusqu'à jusqu'à la fin de
l'année nous avons encore un gros
problème avec les loups et nous allons
avoir des activités depuis son de 50%
donc dans quelles mesures on peut avec
et par rapport au chiffre d'affaires qui
sera fait c'est important nous rappelle
enfin dernièrement les lézatois ils
n'ont pas tout à fait sur les terres des
opérations que nous avons subis suite à
le faire mais au lendemain donc encore
beaucoup de travail à voir alors voilà
le premier ministre annonçait également
que plus de huit cent mille personnes
sont désormais inscrits à pôle emploi à
cause de cette crise sanitaire
est-ce qu'on a eu une idée des chiffres
qui touchent votre profession elle a
très clairement donc ce qui va se passer
dans beaucoup de cas fait que nous
une partie sur le jeu pour cause d'excès
pour l'instant on espère bien sûr les
réponses rapides aux styles et je
couvrais est-il encore que nous ayons
atteindre activités ce n'est pas parce
qu'ils savent être épuisant ça va être
un vrai problème
nous avons affaire ici sur les anti âge
est ce que nous devons et nous avons
aussi un vrai souci pour eux on trouve
des apprentis à mettre dans cette étape
ou en maintenant nos métiers de demain
c'est un port à l'autre bt sur une des
conséquences de ce problème
merci beaucoup parlent du verre
j'ai d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle
que vous êtes président délégué du
syndicat des restaurateurs génie
faillite et on va tout de suite partir
devant l'hôtel matignon retrouver notre
reporter thomas gonnet thomas bonjour
alors que peut-on retenir de l'ags
location de l'allocution paravent du
premier ministre et le premier ministre
a livré une farce des versions
d'assouplissement de ses mesures
sanitaires qui sont en place désormais
depuis le 11 mai la phase 2 du
déconfinement entrera en vigueur à
partir du 2 juin prochain
les nouvelles sont bonnes a déclaré
edouard philippe ferrand tout débute son
allocution il a toutefois appelé les
français à rester vigilants et une
mesure était dans tous les esprits la
suppression d'une mesure était dans tous
les esprits celle de la règle des 100 km
le premier ministre qui a confirmé que
cette règle ne serait plus en place donc
à compter du 2 juin n'a plus de
justification je propose d'écouter le
premier ministre aujourd'hui le virus
circule encore très activement dans
certaines parties du monde
c'est pourquoi nous avons décidé
d'évaluer à l'horizon du 15 juin avec
l'ensemble des pays européens
si nos frontières extérieures à l'europe
devait ou non réussir
pour quel ressortissant de quel pays et
avec quelles modalités de 14 n le cas
échéant donc pour tout ce qui est à
l'extérieur de l'espace européen
la décision sera prise collectivement
avec l'ensemble des pays européens à
l'horizon du 15 juin à l'intérieur de
l'europe
l'épidémie est en train de ralentir
c'est vrai en france mais c'est vrai
partout en europe
c'est pourquoi la france sera favorable
à une réouverture des frontières
intérieures de l'europe à compter du 15
juin si la situation sanitaire le permet
bien entendu 114 haine pour les
voyageurs en provenance de pays
européens très importante de la part d'
edouard philippe c'est cette fameuse
carte du déconfinement il n'y aura plus
désormais deux départements
en rouge toute la carte est en vert à
l'exception des départements de l'île de
france ainsi que la guyane et mayotte
dans ces départements les conditions d'
assouplissement de ces mesures
sanitaires vont être un peu différencié
notamment en ce qui concerne les
restaurants puisque on a appris que les
bars et les restaurants pourront rouvrir
à compter du 2 juin sur l'ensemble du
territoire mais sur et dans ces zones
qui resteront sous surveillance et zone
orange alors ce ne seront que les
terrasses qui pourront ouvrir le premier
ministre a détaillé les modalités de
cette réouverture propose de l'écouter
compte tenu de l'évolution de la crise
sanitaire les restaurants bars et cafés
pourront ouvrir dans tous les
départements à partir du 2 juin mais ils
ouvriront avec des restrictions
temporaires dans ceux qui se trouvent
dans les zones oranges
là où une vigilance particulière est
nécessaire
les personnes qui ont choisi de dîner ou
de déjeuner ensemble pourront s'asseoir
à la même table dans la limite d'une
capacité maximale de 10 par table mais
il devrait y avoir une distance minimale
d'un mètre entre les tables de sacs
groupe dans les départements qui font
l'objet d'une vigilance particulière les
départements de l'île de france
mayotte et la guyane
seuls les terrasses des cafés et des
bars et des restaurants pourront ouvrir
au 2 juin
autre réouverture différenciée selon les
zones vertes où orange sont les salles
de spectacle les gymnases ou les
piscines qui pourront ouvrir dès le 2
juin dans ces zones vertes mais qui en
revanche ne pourrons rouvrir qu'à partir
du 22 juin dans les zones oranges la
date du 22 juin c'est aussi la date à
laquelle pourront rouvrir les cinémas et
les établissements culturels en région
parisienne un mot était à donner
également sur les modalités de rentrée
dans les collèges dans les lycées il y
avait le ministre de l'éducation jean
michel blanquer requis a expliqué que la
rentrée que tous les collèges tous les
collèges allait réouvrir ainsi que
toutes les écoles avec une capacité
maximum de 15 élèves par classe toutes
ces modalités ont été détaillées par le
ministre de l'éducation nationale qui a
également fait savoir que l'oral de
français pour l'épreuve du baccalauréat
serait basée sur le contrôle continu
voilà pour les principales annonces de
la part du premier ministre et des deux
ministres qui étaient présents à ses
côtés et dort philippe qui appelle
encore les français malgré s'est absout
plissement à faire preuve d'esprit de
responsabilité
merci beaucoup thomas pour toutes ces
précisions thomas bonnin en direct
depuis matignon matignon où l'on va
retourner le premier ministre continue
de s'exprimer répond aux questions des
journalistes avec notamment le ministre
de l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer actuellement alors ces deux
questions bien distinctes en effet
d'abord sur le premier point
je rappelle que l'instruction est
obligatoire dans la période
exceptionnelle que nous vivons la seule
chose qui peut être fait entre un élève
et un autre c'est le fait d'aller
physiquement ou pas à l'école mais
l'instruction est obligatoire
concrètement ça signifie qu'on doit soit
à l'école souhaite dans un bien grâce à
l'enseignement à distance mais un élève
ne doit pas être dans une situation sans
aucune scolarisation sans aucun lien
avec l'école
nous savons tous que healy a pour autant
malgré ces principes eu du décrochage
pendant le confinement nous l'avons
chiffré à 4 % en moyenne
mais c'est parfois beaucoup plus qu'en
certains endroits parce que ça n'est
qu'une qu'une moyenne
je rappelle que en europe nous sommes
probablement l'un des pays qui a eu
quand même le moins de décrochage
scolaire ça reste un phénomène important
que nous évaluons donc à environ cinq
cent mille élèves alors sur la première
dimension de votre question ce qui est
important de dire c'est que même un
élève de 4e et de 3e en jour nouveau
range garde un lien avec son collège par
l'enseignement à distance et peut-être
conformément à ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure
parce que son collège va quand même
réussir après avoir ouvert 6e et 5e à
ouvrir 4e et 3e
ensuite s'agissant des lycéens n'a
toujours en zone orange puisque en zone
en zone verte c'est à dire pourquoi une
très grande majorité de la france il ya
ce lien va exister
j'ai bien indiqué qu'il y avait un
entretien individuel ce qui est
évidemment quelque chose d'important
autrement dit tout élève a vocation à
retrouver physiquement à un moment donné
son établissement et avoir quelque chose
qui finalement ne se passe pas tellement
forcément en temps ordinaire qui est de
d'avoir un entretien individuel qui peut
aller loin et qui peut aussi aller vers
des courants tout petits groupes ciblés
pour telle catégorie d'élèves
donc on va aller vers une
personnalisation maximale du lien entre
l'établissement
l'élève et sa famille donc c'est pas du
tout la rupture des liens au contraire
c'est l'aménagement des choses pour
tenir compte des contraintes sanitaires
qui sont fortes c'est vrai mais aussi du
fait qu'on veut faire réussir tous les
élèves de ce point de vue là sur sur
votre deuxième question
enfin la deuxième dimension de votre
question c'est une certaine façon ma
priorité principale nous devons encore
aujourd'hui aller chercher les élèves
qui en ont le plus besoin
il est malheureusement exact de dire
qu'au mois de mai c'est pas forcément
eux qui sont venus en premier c'était
malheureusement ce que l'on pouvait
attendre et donc nous avons déclenché
toute une série de mobilisations et nous
continuons pour que le mois de juin
permettent ces élèves de venir
je pense par exemple au cp ce1 de réseau
d'éducation prioritaire
ils sont par définition dans des groupes
de douze élèves ils peuvent donc venir
tels quels si je puis dire
et aujourd'hui nous n'avons qu'une
partie d'entre eux on doit aller les
chercher d'où la mobilisation générale
par exemple des assistantes sociales de
l'éducation nationale et des
départements mais aussi d'autres
d'autres catégories de la population je
pense aux élus qui sont très mobilisés
sur un tel sujet nos professeurs qui
téléphonent aux familles nos directeurs
directrices d'école bref c'est un peu la
mobilisation générale pour aller
chercher les élèves qui en ont le plus
besoin les rassurer grâce au protocole
sanitaire et personnaliser leur parcours
on a aussi reçu beaucoup de questions
concernant les voyages les vacances et
déplacements les frontières d'abord
peut-être une précision vous avez dit
que la france garderait ses frontières
fermées jusqu'au 15 juin minimum
comment est ce possible alors que
certains pays européens voisins rouvrent
leurs leur aéroport dès la semaine
prochaine comment vous comptez procédé
nous l'avons dit s'agissant des
frontières extérieures à l'europe nous
devons prendre ensemble des décisions
qui permettent de savoir quels sont les
pays
le virus circule à un point tel qu'il ne
serait pas raisonnable de laisser entrer
sur notre territoire des ressortissants
ou des voyageurs en provenance de ces
pays
ça n'a pas de sens de le faire pays par
pays ou plus exactement pays européen
par pays européens il faut le faire
collectivement est ensuite appliqué
cette règle collectivement c'est notre
ambition c'est notre volonté c'est ce à
quoi nous travaillons avec nos
partenaires
entre pays européens la question est un
peu différente certains pays ayant
choisi avant d'autres de ré ouvrir leurs
frontières c'est-à-dire de faire en
sorte qu' on puisse arriver chez eux
moi je respecte les décisions prises par
les pays voisins
elles ont été prise souverainement si
j'ose dire
et elles sont toujours adaptés à la
situation sanitaire
que ce soit en italie ou en espagne la
crise a été d'une telle ampleur que nous
savons que les autorités en place font
le maximum et ne prennent pas des
décisions à la légère je n'ai aucun
doute là dessus mais nous nous prenons
les décisions à notre rythme et nous
avons considéré que le bon moment pour
faire en sorte que l'on puisse accéder
sur le territoire national ce soit le 15
juin et après le 15 juin nous verrons
comment est venue nous ouvrirons les
frontières à l'intérieur de l'europe je
les ai indiqué 149 sont 14èmes de lire
quarantaine 114 n mais avec la
possibilité de prendre des mesures en
réciprocité si des pays européens
venaient à prendre des mesures de 14
haine à l'égard des français
et voilà comment les choses vont
procéder on a encore beaucoup de travail
sur ces questions beaucoup de travail
pratiques à mettre en oeuvre mais il me
semble important de dire à nos
concitoyens quelle est la perspective la
perspective c'est le 15 juin ce n'est
pas le 2 juin et dans les conditions
qu'on aura l'occasion de préciser et
donc concrètement un français qui
voudraient se rendre en italie dès la
semaine prochaine pourrait français qui
voudraient se rendre en italie pourrait
ils pourraient se rendre en italie au
sens ou l'italie ne lui interdit ne lui
interdirait pas l'accès à son territoire
mais et que nous n'interdisons pas
l'accès à notre territoire des
ressortissants français quand ils
reviennent en france
vous savez c'est déjà le cas aujourd'hui
mais un ressortissant étranger ne
pourrait pas aller en italie revenir en
france facilement une question de
l'outre-mer 360 qui concerne le sujet
très spécifique d outre mer du pacifique
qu'en est il pour leur déplacement à eux
qui font nécessairement une escale à
faire aux états unis pour la polynésie
par exemple au japon pour la nouvelle
calédonie alors je vais pas être en
mesure de répondre à toutes les
questions et notamment aux questions
d'escale parce qu'elles dépendent des
régimes juridiques de chaque pays et au
risque de vous décevoir je ne suis pas
capable de déterminer dans le détail le
régime juridique applicable dans tous
les pays du monde
j'en suis désolé mais honnêtement je ne
vois pas comment je pourrais orange qui
est certain c'est que ce soit en
polynésie ou en nouvelle calédonie et
singulièrement nouvelle calédonie il y à
un régime de 14 haine auxquels les
populations de nouvelle calédonie sont
extrêmement attachés
d'abord à cause de leur histoire la
propagation des virus
apportez de l'extérieur a bien souvent
suscité des ravages considérables dans
l'histoire de ces territoires et nous
avons donc veiller à faire en sorte que
les 14 n applicable en nouvelle
calédonie et en polynésie soit très
strictes et à faire en sorte que chacun
puisse les observer et de ce point de
vue là il y a un enjeu très particulier
nous ne voulons prendre aucun risque en
la matière comme je l'aï indiqué tout à
l'heure
ce que nous cherchons à faire c'est tout
en garantissant les conditions de sûreté
et de sécurité sanitaire veillez à
imaginer des nouveaux protocoles qui
permettrait d'accéder plus facilement
aux territoires insulaires mais avec
toutes les conditions de sûreté garantie
et c'est un travail qu'il faut faire
avec les médecins pour vérifier que le
protocole que nous proposerons sera
parfaitement adapté aux enjeux
nous avons un certain nombre de
questions économiques notamment cette
question de l' afp tf1 lci vous en avez
d'ailleurs parlé vous même l'urgence
économique illustrée par les mauvais
chiffres du chômage une reprise
hésitante
est ce que tout ça ça a dicté
l'accélération du déconfinement j'ai
indiqué très tôt n'avait pas encore
commencé avec le déconfinement avant le
11 mai que à l'évidence après le choc
sanitaires il y aura un choc économique
et social
personne en vérité ne pouvait imaginer
que une interruption aussi brutale de la
production est aussi massive de la
consommation dans presque la moitié des
pays du monde
en tout cas pour la moitié de l'humanité
passerait inaperçue évidemment elle
provoque un choc économique massif
je les dis dès le début je le savais
d'ailleurs en vérité tout le monde le
sait donc cette question n'a pas
justifié une accélération ni un
ralentissement de considérations qui ont
été prises d'abord et avant tout pour
protéger les populations
mais il est vrai que j'ai toujours
évoqué la question du chemin de crête
entre la sécurité sanitaire et la
nécessaire reprise
aujourd'hui on voit que la pente
du côté de la sécurité sanitaire est un
peu moins difficile mais que la pente du
côté de la reprise économique est
beaucoup plus abrupte nous devons donc
continuer d'avancer
nous sommes toujours sur ce chemin de
crête mais parce que les résultats
sanitaires sont bons nous pouvons
avancer plus vite
comptez vous renforcer les contrôles
face aux entreprises qui ont indûment
utilisé le dispositif de chômage partiel
en faisant travailler alors ça le
premier ministre edouard philippe
continue donc d'échanger avec les
journalistes depuis matignon après avoir
présenté les mesures de la deuxième
étape du plan de déconfinement à 20
heures stéphanie de murs rue avec ses
invités reviendra largement sur ces
mesures annoncées par le gouvernement
mais avant dans 30 minutes c'est
interdit d'interdire avec frédéric
taddeï excellente soirée sur rt france
[Musique]
et
on est allé faire ailleurs ce qu'on
voulait faire chez nous mais qui coûtait
trop cher à faire chez nous avons
aujourd'hui les usines qui ferment en
france pour se mettre dans les pays de
l'est en pologne en roumanie ailleurs
selon vous sommes nous allés trop loin
dans la mondialisation
le principal problème c'est c'est aussi
l'europe et l'euro on est allé trop loin
surtout dans la désindustrialisation
notre pays en france on trouve pas mal
de choses